often times you're seeing a scene play
out that you think you see the whole
thing in the trailer and then it
progresses and you're like oh they
didn't give away like this because there
was still a number of moments especially
in the scary parts of the movie that
audibly made me go oh yeah so we just
saw it the 2017 edition Stephen King
adaptation / remake of a 1990 miniseries
chapter 1 this movie was quite an
experience man I'm not gonna beat around
the bush I really enjoyed the hell out
of this movie it's not terrifying but it
is an experience of emotions throughout
I think when you see the trailers are
expecting this really serious tension
film movie with killer Klown and it's so
much more than that the way I felt about
this movie was a kept switching from
heartfelt to a lot of laughter this
movie surprisingly SuperDuper funny and
then oh my god there was a terrifying
scene I forgot that there's horror in
this movie yeah yeah I mean the heart
and soul is the ensemble of the loser
club yeah and I mean you know they're
all pretty great in this I mean they
have great chemistry together even some
of the characters that don't get to be
as big you know they all get a moment
yeah and this felt like a Stephen King
novel in terms of how colorful the
characters are the kids are written
super well the bully characters are
written pretty damn well actually I can
spend forever comparing the kid portion
of the miniseries to this but I also
haven't read the book so I don't really
want to just do that because the
original source material is not the
miniseries however I gotta say I
definitely enjoyed this more than the
Martian of who where the kids are in it
miniseries the kids here are so lovable
yeah they sound like real kids their
chemistry and banter is fantastic
sometimes it just sounds so damn natural
the dude who plays will and stranger
things
[Music]
he's kinda like the pervert dude in the
group II beep Ritchie was so freaking
hysterical
oh yeah mayn't kid in the group a dude
named bill he has a stutter going on the
whole time and he did so naturally
everyone in this group has such natural
dynamics and the other kid Eddie the one
who has like the really controlling
mother in the group the chemistry was so
on par and their banter back and forth
was so wonderfully fantastic you fall in
love with this loser group which makes
all the other scenes so effective as
you're watching the rest of this movie
unfold oh yeah one a ton of that goes to
help the movie overall because you
really feel like this is a small town
for real like you mostly get to know the
kids but you also get to know a couple
the peripheral characters and you do get
to know a few of their families you see
what everybody's up against him what the
people in this town are like and it does
really make use of its setting you know
that always in the sewer or in the river
at the rock quarry or something like
that you know or at the school yeah this
is kind of an expansive movie for that I
know that the kid portion was originally
in the 50s they said this in the 80s and
the director Andrew and reimu Shetty
Andy mushiya Andy machete he definitely
made this an 80s film about it funny how
like something like stranger things was
inspired by material like it the new it
movie takes inspiration from things like
stranger oh yeah yeah but they really
commit to the 80s in here and I and I
appreciate it because it's sometimes
it's like okay that's super 80s and kind
of in my face but most of the time I
like the little touches like you see in
the background of the theater there
playing Batman and lethal weapon - and
they don't know hone in on that but it's
just a nice little 80's touch to have
and Nightmare on Elm Street 5 yeah yeah
I thought that they did a nice job of
that too and there's not like a crazy
synth score and yeah in fact the music
is pretty varied and it harkens back to
older eras of cinema as well as newer
ones there are some like really 8 keys
synth sound yeah they're also some
really crisp flute sounds
there's a lot of great detail and that's
sort of what shines the most for me in
this man the film is shot incredibly
well - oh yeah it's beautiful organic
and there's some wonderful visual
effects and pretty well edited - All
Things Considered cuz there's a lot of
weird Dutch angles that have to all
match each other and stuff a really
distinct visual and really well
assembled movie overall and you feel a
lot during this movie that was the main
thing I feel like if you go into this
film expecting the terrifying experience
you're probably not gonna get that you
might have a few moments that provide a
good jump scare you might have a few
moments that might truly terrify you I
personally wasn't ever terrified but I
was always having a good time there were
times I thought it was scary and a
little bit on the edge of my seat I was
always heavily invested in what was
going on it's more than just a horror
movie and of course you know the one
thing we haven't mentioned anyone is
there's one thing from the it miniseries
a lot of people like call it a campy
corny thing and I call it that too but
one thing we all take away from that
miniseries is Tim Curry's performance
Bill's skarsgård had this daunting task
of I got to do my own thing here and not
have people just keep comparing me to
penny wise because of the way the
approach of this film was taken it
allowed him to do a different type of
performance as well there's only one
scene here that I'm like oh yeah that's
definitely in the miniseries the whole
like take it scene from sewer scene yeah
but they even do something different
with that at the end of that scene that
you don't get in the middie series and I
was like oh this is definitely the movie
and not the made-for-tv movie you know
yeah they take full advantage of
generating in this it's violent and it's
pretty sweet and messed up at times too
because you know the horror is not just
bloody and icky it's all so surreal yeah
and unnerving yeah like if I had a
complaint about this movie I would say
like I was missing a bit of tension or
suspense perhaps yeah but I thought all
their ideas and the execution of all the
horrific scenes you know it's pretty
good because this movie has a lot to get
done in you know 2 hours and 20 minutes
which is already kind of long for a
horror movie so I don't necessarily
blame them well it's a really character
driven horror movie
yeah and that that drives everything
home and that makes the scary scenes you
know that
much higher in terms of snacks I thought
the visual effects were pretty damn good
actually I could see some people kind of
walking out of this being like it's a
little too heavy on some CGI and there's
a couple of moments where I'm like
that's very Andy machete like there's
one specific type of fear element where
like that straight out of mama right
there oh yeah I don't want to give
anything away but there was a couple of
really fantastic visual effects scenes
where I did not see this specific
creature fear-based moment coming and it
was extremely well liked oftentimes
you're seeing a scene play out that you
think you see the whole thing in the
trailer and then it progresses and
you're like oh they didn't give away
this because there was still a number of
moments especially in the scary parts of
the movie that audibly made me go
[Music]
watching trailers are doing reactions
it's like I'm really letting out how I
feel but in movies I'm very anal about
just like being a quiet movie goer but
there were times where I was very
audible even moments were like there was
[ __ ] happening on the screen where I
noticed my face and I rarely even do
this even in the horror I was like yeah
[Music]
there's some truly creepy stuff but bill
skarsgård does he does a really good job
and I like the way who she Eddy captured
a lot of his scenes this is an
interesting effect that you do see some
of it in the trailers whenever he runs
he does the head shaky thing and then
like the cameras looks like he's steady
but everything else is like yeah it's a
creepy thing kind of his face is always
like perfectly still with this thing out
of it in a really eerie kind of way what
I think a lot of people don't realize
about it is that it's more than just
kids versus a clown it's a clown of
someone who hones in on your worst fears
yeah and uses that to sort of weekend
you and prey upon you yes with your
imagination this film takes full
advantage of that and a really really
well done way one thing yeah give the
miniseries is that there's some pretty
impressive practical effects this foam
relies a little bit more on CGI than
practical but there's some good
practical the CGI is pretty good to the
point where I would sometimes get pretty
scared of what I would see
on screen I mean they got a DI to do the
effects in this movie and those guys are
you know top-notch and it shows you know
it does definitely show if there was a
couple of things I would have liked you
see for what I got I can't really
complain about it there's like moments
here or there where I'm like this seems
a little off I'm cool with like 80s
montage of these kids cleaning up
something horrific but based off
everything we've seen so far I would
have expected a different response from
them you see the mone like overall
demeanor walls yeah
orchestrating that see Nina and I know
bill skarsgård worked his ass off on
developing a character for this movie a
full-fledged performances I'm sure he
was very much aware of like Tim Curry as
penny wise so he wanted to really give
his own specific take I really feel like
there's only maybe one or two scenes
where we get to see his full-on
performance all the homework you gotta
do cuz most of the time you see penny
wise it's a bunch of crazy scare [ __ ]
going on a bunch of crazy visuals
happening and it's the performance that
you want to see a little bit more of to
make him such a signature penny wise for
us I feel like when you watch like Tim
Curry you're you remember how he talks
how he interacts and all that stuff and
I would have just liked a little bit
more of that maybe like one or two more
scenes for a movie two hours or 20
minutes so much did I get what we don't
get a bed there's a couple of scenes I
can think of where I'm like I really
love those scenes when it's just penny
wise kind of just talking you know I
could have used a little more although
I'm in the middle on that because part
of me is like good on you guys for
leaving us wanting more baby yeah like
for not giving us too much and making
him completely unscary I'm kind of with
you I could have done with a little bit
more but as it stands it with as much as
this movie has to do I still got a
decent glimpse I know you you haven't
seen the miniseries but when it cuts to
the adults in the miniseries you do get
a lot more penny wise talking as opposed
to the kid portion so I'm sure we'll get
more that thing I wanted that's CSU
leaves me wanting that and I feel like
I'm they're gonna deliver that in this
in part two if that's what's coming up
that I'm just going to currently beyond
upset that there's not more penny last
movie you know if there's going to be
definitely more and if he's gonna get
another chance to shine out in this
character which I can't imagine why he
wouldn't I'm excited to see and I like
the way everything's really interwove
in' you know for a film
is a chapter one in a two-part movie in
a day and age of movies we are built on
franchise setting up sequels it ends in
a way where you're like you know I know
we're getting a sequel yeah but we just
happen to fail the box I'm sorry what I
needed you could end it here it's that
good of an installment of a film they
just focus on one damn good movie I
thought they did such a good job with
that I guess a couple other things sort
of like to pretty much everyone in the
losers Club it has a lot of time to be
fleshed out and there was just a couple
of kids in there where I'm like they set
them up to get fleshed out they set them
up to have big payoffs but I kind of
feel like there are a little push to the
background a little bit more there's the
Jewish kids stand that's what I
remembered I and then the black kid Mike
like that's all I really remember about
them I know their backstory because they
told it to us everyone else gets a lot
more rewarding screen time and bigger
payoffs and their characters are more
written yes to you know and and I kind
of hoped especially the way Mike enters
the story like I kind of hope that
gantter would grow or or just get more
time to be commissioned because I know
they sent him up you start him off on
his sort of own story and you're kind of
hanging solely attention to him for a
little bit until he meets the losers
Club yeah at that point I was like oh
yeah I thought you were gonna be a part
of this movie more yeah there's a group
of bullies in this movie in the main
boolean and Henry after seeing the
miniseries which I thought is super
corny and the miniseries here this this
guy does a great job and I love the way
they flesh out his character because as
his character progresses and we see
where they're going with it it makes
sense and it adds up to a really
satisfying point for me where I'm like
wow I didn't actually see that coming
but they were hinting at that from the
very beginning yeah yeah yeah when
you've got all these explorations of
fear and the movies sort of like about
what you do in the face of fear you know
like it is a creature that feeds off of
and the whole point is you're supposed
to band together in a haven and so like
that character is a whole other side of
that coin where he's clearly fearful of
his father and angry and just warping
worse and worse becomes the scariest
thing about this movie
yeah like just watching him twist well
that's what I mean because you have a
few storylines going on here you have
all their individual storylines and you
got the story of them as a group and
then you have them dealing with this
[ __ ] clown then you've got these
bullies it is cruel dude okay and by the
time in the movies coming to its finale
it all comes together pretty damn well
even though I've seen the miniseries I
was like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and the
girl Beverly and there's other female
characters in here but she's the one
female character in here a lot of white
kids I mean the plot does actually make
a point to be like we're not very
open-minded in this town yeah but
Beverly that character I thought was
really well-written I really appreciated
the hell out of that actresses
performance yeah and a group of where
it's like a bunch of dudes and you know
she does a damn good job in there
she kind of reminds me of like a really
young Amy Adams innocence yeah I get
where you're going down yeah she has a
very magical enchanting performant I
mean like the whole point is you're
supposed to kind of be along with the
kids so you do in a weird way sort of
fall in love with her the fat kid Ben oh
man you is probably my really might have
in the first half of the movie he was my
favorite one of the losers Club
ya know Chris for the first half he is
the sweet one yeah yeah the only guy
who's like kinda sweet yeah and also
alone so it's like easy to I really I
really did like him a lot and I got you
at the fin well farm when I see wolfhard
when he was catch sounds like a cool
when he was cast in this movie I was
like of course I got the kid from one of
the kids from stranger things to be in
this but he is not playing will from
stranger things in this he's a totally
different type of kid in this he is so
freaking awesome he easily got the
biggest laughs throughout the entire
film yeah and so well except for what
Eddie has one that that ruined me
there's one joke from Eddie that kept
John and I laughing like a whole whole
scene later you have that one laugh
where you just you have laughter shocks
throughout the next five minutes all in
all I feel like this movie managed to
balance a lot of tones
yes Madison the main three tones is
humor heart and horror and I thought it
managed to weave all three together in
such a nice
blend it's one of those things where you
know we saw the face your fears behind
the scenes thingy
where they're talking about how we
wanted to make this an emotional movie
to a lot of times you see this behind
the scenes [ __ ] director say stuff and
you're and then you watch mean you're
like it was nothing like what they were
attending it's very emotional
and it's terrifying this guy nailed it I
thought he pretty much nailed the whole
thing yeah I gotta say I liked mama
you know I like the short and I liked
the movie okay I didn't love it but I
thought it was good and this was like I
was very impressed by him oh yeah I see
why you got this movie and I am excited
to see where you go cuz this is really I
thought was a very strongly in assuredly
directed movie oh absolutely no like his
hand behind the camera is steady and it
seems very clear that he knew exactly
how I wanted to shoot this and
especially coming off of Cary Fukunaga
project yeah I know which was so
developed at the time that he left you
know like kudos to him Tanny movie Eddie
it seemed like he still got to do the
Boosh Yeti thing it didn't seem like
kind of how I'm feeling about how the
Han Solo spin-off is going yeah like we
need a director to just come in here and
just do what we want him to do it yeah
it didn't feel that way at all I'm
curious as to what Cary Fukunaga movie
would have been so it's a co-writing
credit yeah and some of those ideas are
you know still in here but you know I'm
not missing it now because I'm like this
guy I'm I am really thrilled for him
because I he impressed me with this
movie I thought was pretty good with
Mama he impressed me yeah he redefined I
think he redefined it not just for a
modern-day audience but I just think in
totality he's redefined what it is
Stephen King is telling the truth about
yeah I had hopes but I was not prepared
for how good it really was he's not
James Cameron asam this is going to Rio
Jessie simpler I really had in mind you
the new film which in my mind I think of
as the third film this is a really do we
steal this time
um I give it 10 its what is an int who
knows I give in 99 red balloons knocking
off one red balloon for you know plain
sweet yeah yeah yeah alright guys did
you see it the movie
that's what I'm referring to when I see
it would you think comment subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell tell me why I'm wearing a True
Blood shirt John is - on Humphry on
Twitter and Instagram follow him there
and go check out our patreon patreon
comm slash the real rejects become a
patreon eject today what does that mean
go there to find out output